my name is maureen bear and i'm here
with my colleagues ben kickert who is
just speaking and Benji Bernstein and
connect Lake
we're from starting up good and we work
on the sustainable development goals and
this is more about the X then about
Wolfram coding Benji and Ben did a
presentation on Twitter that involved a
lot of coding and there's a presentation
that they're doing at 1:30 this
afternoon that will do more looking at
data structures and how to use them what
I'd like to talk about today is what is
SDG counting this is our fifth year or
my fifth year at least coming to Wolfram
and talking about it and we're what
we've been doing what we're doing in the
future and also to talk about how you
embed Wolfram in the way that you do
your work the way that you do your
projects and give give some ideas about
how you can work with people who were in
different places on the Wolfram
knowledge spectrum
so first the sustainable development
goals when I came in five years ago
I see John keel is here he was my first
friend at Wolfram who we started talking
about the sustainable development goals
which are this strategic plan for the
world they were launched by the United
Nations in 2015 they go for 15 years
there are 17 goals around all aspects of
poverty education life underwater
partnerships health and during the 15
years the countries of the world in the
world as a whole and others are
measuring success in improvement of the
world using 169 targets and 232
indicators these were developed by years
of collaboration so that all countries
could participate
understand what it was going to take to
make the world a better place in 2030
needless to say they're aspirational
although it'd be great if they were all
accomplished five years in which is
about a third of the time some things
are going well some things are not going
as well one of the very interesting
things that happen is when we started
there was very little data a lot of time
had been spent talking about the
framework and what was going to happen
what we found over the past five years
is that many many organizations that
people have actually bought into this as
their frameworks most corporations have
SDG frameworks for looking at their
corporate social responsibility
universities teach courses on it and
have labs about it
foundations give money to the SDGs
financial institutions set up investment
funds around the sustainable development
goals many cities have their own plans
every single country in the world has
bought into it one way or another
what are the reasons if that's happened
is that they've been allowed to select
which goals and targets they're going to
go after and what that means is that
each country has a customized plan that
meets their needs so everything from the
United States and the UK to the poorest
and least developed country in the world
is involved with this China Russia
everybody so it's been exciting because
from having nothing
we actually have too much data now so a
lot of our work has been about the too
much data so we'll talk a little bit
about that and how we've we've we've
pivoted a few times in terms of what
we've been doing for a couple of
different reasons
so the SDG counting project when we
started out the idea was been had been
in Swaziland working in health
development on a mission and he was the
guy who did most of the metrics and
reporting and years ago before the SDG
started better than I started talking
about he would enter his data by being
with the people in the field who were
doing the health work
and I had another friend named Chris
Collins who was working at the UN and he
was the guy who got all the role to
update at the very top and we were all
fascinated about how much the data and
the conclusions changed from where Ben
was entering it at the very beginning to
where Chris was working with the
consolidators at the very top and what
we noticed is that in a roll up of
information you you lose things you gain
things you average things out so the the
15 year goal of this project is is what
I'd like to say you know write wants
read many so the data is captured as
close to the ground as possible and
rolls all the way up without being
changed its consolidated and things like
that so that you are having the same
data picture of the world so that when
people are doing metrics they can all be
looking at the same data again
aspirational so Eric our project is just
as aspirational as the SVG goals are but
what the heck you have 15 years we
decided that Wolfram was perfect for
this because it's iterative you can add
to it over time new things are coming
out all the time as the technology
changes you don't lose your coding we
thought we wouldn't have to switch and
it was relatively easy to use at the
very beginning I was the one who was
doing the coding and I'm not a coder
since over the past five years I've
started working with with others who
were better coders than me
much better corners than me and we've
been looking at how to integrate and now
how to look at all the different data
sources and begin to understand how they
relate to each other so we've been
looking Ben mentioned earlier and Benji
mentioned that we've been looking at SDG
14 which is about life under the sea
because not too many people were looking
at it we had some other reasons so our
revolution has been when I go back to
the presentation that I gave here five
years ago
we've accomplished a whole lot but we
have an accomplishment I thought we
would but we'll keep on track of their
this the other thing we did was
selecting projects based on where there
were niches for us what we at the
beginning we didn't know what was going
to happen in terms of counting so what
we thought was going to happen was that
we would be consolidating the
information that came into the UN what
we found is there's plenty of people
doing that and bet we'll be talking a
little bit more about that but what we
found really interesting is that where
the action is is actually around
startups around investments and around
what's going on in the startup and and
innovation ecosystems so we've been
focusing on that more over the past
several years so our current work our
badge is some of our badges at least
they starting up good so we have two
different organizations one called
starting up good which is working with
startups to help them understand how to
position themselves better for getting
investment and how to use the
sustainable development goals as a way
to position themselves we do all of our
workers pro bono we have clients pro
bono clients we went to New York Tech
Day last year and found six startups
that were already working in so doing
things with social impact energy
management using music for PTSD looking
at journalism in a more fair way looking
at what's going on with SDG 14 and some
others and we brought them on with us
because we wanted to be working in the
real world not just with data in our
last presentation we talked a little
about Twitter and there's a lot more but
what we found is that it's very
important to be looking at social media
and how you're positioning yourself in
order to be attractive to impact
investors you want to be where the
impact investors are and Sgt counting
while we talk
about a little more later today and
impact investing is sort of the fulcrum
of where we are on a lot of our
different projects so I wanted to take
you through a couple of small case
studies of things that we've been doing
the first one is looking at building
computational knowledge on SGG 14 which
is life under water about conserving and
sustainably using the oceans seas and
marine resources for sustainable
development and here what we wanted to
do is figure out how to get as much
comprehensive information as possible on
one of the SDGs and to amplify the
ability of the subject matter expert in
the BlueTEC economy in order to
influence the field so one of the people
we've been working with a guy named
chris is an expert in bringing people
together a convener and he knows a whole
lot of people who were working in
BlueTEC and on the SDGs and what we
found is that it's very important to
combine human intelligence with the
kinds of things that Wolfram can do for
you
so Canet liaison with people with the
different pro bono clients spend a lot
of time talking with chris and doing you
could formally call it knowledge
engineering but what she was actually
doing was sort of picking his brain to
try to understand all the people he's
met and all the things that he does and
putting it into a form that could be
used as data for future projects and so
a lot of time had been spent doing that
and she used LinkedIn connections
Twitter personal conversations it went
into a data set we amplified that by
using wolfram web search to look at the
ecosystem we used web image search
Twitter Wikipedia data and we use text
cases to refine the data and what we
found in all of our work is that there
are so many different places where small
pieces of Wolfram code can be really
helpful to moving ahead the project we
cross-referenced all of our web search
findings to identify knowledge gaps and
mixed network connections in the
influenced person influencers personal
map and we're working now with Chris to
use the information so that he can go
out and make connections with people
make connections with the right people
be attending the right events have his
social media presence be somebody be
some way that sees him as a convener and
we ultimately are hoping to use SDG 14
and the work that we've done with Chris
to as a model for all 17 of the SDGs and
to publish online a compendium of where
all the information is where you can
find it and what you can do with it I
wanted to talk a little bit I think I'll
talk a little bit about what it's like
to be working in a team with Wolfram
because of the wide breadth of it that
you could do almost anything with
Wolfram in most cases there are other
things other software other ways of
doing things other software languages
they could do any one thing probably
better but the power is that you could
tie everything together and it's
relatively readable so when you're
talking about computational X you have
to pay a lot of attention to all the
people that you want to be working with
who are not necessarily coders and you
have to figure out how to have processes
that bring people who code together with
people who don't
code in a way that lets the team work
together we've done a whole lot of work
as a team because we have a SPECT we're
on a spectrum in terms of how we code
can that has been our primary user and
brings a really relevant perspective to
we we cadet has joined us here for a
Wolfram conference and it's a little
like joy coming to a cult when you're
not in it but she's but we talk about
Wolfram all the time we use it as our
organizing principle and canet is the
one who says to ban and Benjy and me all
this code is great but is that really
what the client needs is that really
what the project needs this user
interface is is too complicated
so so what we find is the going back and
forth is is really important when you're
looking at the computational X you have
to understand how everybody talks to
each other and these in these things we
also find that when you're looking at
what the topics are you need to almost
build an ontology but it's always a
fuzzy ontology the information is
changing very quickly there's so much of
us and what we see is that the
information needs to have categories
that you can change categories that are
understandable to people with different
language circles and that there has to
be some common understanding of how
you're using wolfram to bring all of
your things together the final thing
that we do is we look at collaboration
with the clients that we're working with
the pro bono clients in a way that we
apply Wolfram to help them with their
real-world issues so if somebody says I
need to find out more about companies
that are doing blue tech in Europe we
will then actually work with them using
Wolfram to figure out how we might do
something like that so we're working
iteratively with them we're working all
with people who were on the other side
of impact investing to determine what
impact investors need to know more about
and where the data is on that so we're
tying all these things together we're
using the SDGs as sort of our conceptual
framework and we're using Wolfram as our
back backbone framework for all of it so
it's been a very interesting first five
years we're looking forward to the next
ten we we fully expect that we'll be
able to keep on going in terms of
building as the SDGs go on we have some
interesting things coming up I'm going
to skip my code my code is not worth
looking at but when you talk about what
next what we're doing is we're going to
get some more clients we're going to
work more with the clients the pro bono
clients that we have on real world and
real time we're building the
computational knowledge base and the
impact investing space as well there's
more and more data about how people are
investing in the SDGs where where
innovation is in the SDGs we're planning
to share our SDG work with more people
with the UN on some of the SDG counting
work that we've been doing with
influencers and with investors we're
planning in the near future to publish
online a comprehensive guide for each of
the SDGs and to use our social media to
make sure that other people do it and
we're pushing the limits of real world
Wolfram language for rx and we encourage
everybody who has you know something
that they want to bring Wolfram language
to to pay attention to the different
parts of humans and Wolfram language and
AI is coming and we're very excited that
we're working in parallel really nicely
with Wolfram and where we're going in
terms of our projects and I thought I'd
conclude with just a few things that
we're really looking forward to
hopefully in 12 points out the first
thing that's really difficult is that so
many people publish everything in PDFs
and in order to get a whole lot of data
together
you have to do something with all the
PDFs the UN lives on PDFs we look
forward to well from having a capacity
to integrate PDF conversion and reading
into that's the one thing where we have
to go outside to Wolfram to do is the
converting of the PDF well we'd love to
never leave Wolfram for our work the
next is that at then we're pretty sure
that this is going to get better but we
find that semantic identification using
text contents using text cases is not
always at the level it's not always
right I guess would be the right way to
put it
sometimes it is sometimes it's not but
we assume the AI is going to get better
on that and consequently identification
will as well and finally we'd like to
see more up to date data in Wolfram
entities we find that sometimes there's
a lag in the Wolfram entities getting
financial data and country data up so I
thank you for your attention we're
looking forward to the future here and
we'll answer any questions if you have
them
[Applause]